(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Wow.
You guys comfortable?
- Yeah, do I get to keep this mug?
- I'm gonna steal one
your pillows there Ryan.
- Yeah. I'm like, very comfortable.
- [Will] Very comfortable.
Yeah.
- I like you as a host.
- Mhm I do too.
- And as an actress.
- This is good.
- Wow.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- This is very good.
- Thanks guys, I'm actually more
comfortable over here than over there.
- [Ryan] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Good, good.
Get used to it.
- We're gonna ask you questions?
- I don't like to, I don't
like to answer questions.
- I'm the one who took Kelly out
so you could have this opportunity.
(laughter)
- Looking out for me, looking out me
- Dreams do come true.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
- It's really nice to be back together.
- [Will] It is.
- Isn't it?
- I agree.
- As a host, it's my job to make
sure you're all comfortable.
- [Will] Okay.
- So I had some holiday drinks prepared.
To, like, get you settled in.
- Oh.
- Oh my.
- Merry Christmas.
- How cute is this?
That's so cute.
- Merry Christmas.
- Thank you so much buddy
- Thank you so much.
You look, you look familiar.
You look familiar.
- Get that a lot.
- Cheers, thank you so much.
- Yeah, whatever.
Bye, guys.
- What is it?
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- [Ryan] Wow.
- That's, that's the same costume
I wore in the movie.
- Oh, oh yeah.
This is refreshing.
- This is very boozy.
- This is tasty.
- Yeah.
- It's a special booze
that, do you recognize it?
- That's Aviation Gin right there.
- Oh!
- Okay.
- Sure is.
- Way to go guys.
- Ryan, I have a question.
You and Blake are expecting?
- [Audience Member] Woo!
(laughter)
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- Oh my God.
You know?
You know, you know.
- This is how I find out?
Um, yes, yes we are, we are.
- How are you preparing for this new baby?
- Um, God.
Well, the first the first one,
you know, it is, is sweet.
The first one you get,
you know, everything's
like perfect and like, you
just set everything up.
Just everything's sterilized.
By the fourth you're just like,
oh, right, this is happening.
- [Host] Right?
- This is happening, I
should sweep or something.
- It's like in the calendar.
- So not as much preparation
is, is happening.
Now I, I shouldn't speak
for my wife because she's,
yeah she's, she's in it to
win it right now, she's ready.
So, and we're very excited though.
- [Host] That is exciting.
- We're very excited, yeah.
- Congratulations.
- Little extra help around
the house is why I'm...
- That's good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We've got a holiday coming up.
Is anyone planning to be the cook
for Thanksgiving on Thursday?
Any cooks on the couch here?
- Not me.
- Not me
No.
- I'm Canadian, so our
Thanksgiving happened
in October I imagine I will be doing...
- [Host] Good for you.
- I know, right?
(laughter)
- You get two.
We're slightly ahead there, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
You guys cooking?
- We're not.
We, my wife, we, we, we did one year.
We did all right.
Early on.
- Yeah.
- It was just too much...
- [Host] Lots of plans.
- We were halfway through
the Thanksgiving meal going,
"For as much work as it took,
doesn't taste that good."
- No.
- Yeah.
- I know how you feel.
I know how you feel.
- Turkey is a little dry
- Tabia.
- Well, I, I, I just, you
know, try every now and again.
I'm, I'm not good at it.
I'm, I'm not, I, I like to partake.
- [Host] Yeah.
- I don't like to actually try to cook...
- [Host] It's good to...
- Are we talking about drugs or?
(laughter)
- [Host] Yeah.
- What's wrong with her?
My god, I'm so sorry.
- It's okay, it's okay.
- Will you cook, will you and Kenny Cook?
- We, like, bring in some sides, you know?
Everyone pitches in.
- Potluck.
- We do, I like to do
something fun with Pomegranate.
- Oh.
- You know, I like this...
- Aviation Gin.
- A turducken gin.
- Oh
- Let's go nuts.
- I'm so, I'm, I'm getting hungry.
- [Octavia] I know.
- [Ryan] Just cutting through
to that juicy gin center.
- Juicy gin center.
- Right?
Yeah, that's great.
- Is it true you both did the morning
announcements at your high school.
- Yes.
- I did, yes.
You didn't know that?
We never...
- We never knew this.
- Okay.
- Oh, fun to find out.
- I loved it, I, I, loved doing it.
- In between first and
second periods, right?
- I, we, it was, it was before
first period for, for us.
Like, yeah.
I loved it.
I did it for two years.
- Was it pretty straightforward,
just informational?
- [Host] Yeah was there a script?
- It was informational.
And then on pep rally day,
Lily Tomlin had a character
called "Edithan" and I kind
of modeled my character to
get all the kids ready for the pep rally.
Her name was "Ebiliat".
(laughter)
- Nice.
- That's how...
- That's how it works.
- I love it.
- Does your high school have like a
a propagandist who also does it just
like releasing propaganda to the children
before they start the day?
That's what my, that's
what I, that was my job.
- Oh?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You were propagandist.
- Yeah, lead propagandist, yeah.
Kitsilano Secondary School, yeah.
- You just had no questions about that.
- Not at all, of course not.
You gotta shape minds,
you can't let them evolve.
- Wow, wow.
- I was in charge, we were
writing announcements to
sell senior class t-shirts to raise
money for our, our senior activity.
You know, a big trip to
Disneyland or whatever and...
- You grew up in Southern California,
how's that a big trip to Disneyland?
- I mean...
(laughter)
- Good point.
- It was still big.
- You could moonwalk to
Disneyland in high school
- But it was...
- People were trying
not to go to Disneyland.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- We were really excited about Disneyland.
- I'm always excited about Disneyland.
- [Host] I mean, yes.
- Okay, yeah.
- But we didn't go, we
didn't sell enough T-shirt.
- I was gonna say, you
didn't sell enough T-shirts
- I'm just kidding, we
went, we had a great time.
And, and if, if I'd known if you
wouldn't have been
invited, so anti-Disneyland
- No probably not, no absolutely not.
(laughter)
Absolutely not.
- As a talk show host I'm required
to ask you about your
first jobs, I'll start.
- Sure.
- My first job was
driving ice cream trucks.
I was a Mr. Softy ice cream truck...
- You were a Mr. Softy truck driver.
- Wow.
- Yeah, I was a Mr. Softy
ice cream truck driver.
- Oh they would've fired me.
I would've eaten all of the...
(laughter)
- I mean well, it, we
were dropping like flies.
It was like 13 of of us hired to be, like,
the all female contingency of Mr. Softy
called Queen Frostine.
- I parked cars.
- [Host] What did you do?
- I was at valet.
- [Host] Oh, cool.
- I parked cars at a, at a hotel.
And I got, I once left the
keys from another person's car
in a car that drove off for the night.
- [Octavia] Oh.
- Oops.
- So they called me at home.
They're like, "Do you have
any spare keys on you?"
Cause sometimes you grab a bunch
of different keys to
pull up cars in a row.
I was like, "No, I don't."
He was like, "We think you left the keys."
And, uh, and these people had
to just stay at the hotel.
I don't know.
I, somehow, I didn't get fired.
- I was about to say, were
you still gainfully employed?
- I was not let go.
- [Octavia] Wow.
- Yeah.
- [Ryan] Good lord.
- Octavia?
- I worked at a marketing research company
and I worked in the casting office.
- You were a casting or you were
assistant casting director weren't you?
- And the thing is, I now
look back and I probably
wouldn't have gotten the job cause
they were they were terrified of me.
I kept showing up every day.
Hey, have you got anything for me to do?
I'm glad to do it.
- [Ryan] Wow.
- And they finally hired me.
It was like psycho.
I just kept showing up.
- [Host] Really?
- I did, I was persistent.
- That's amazing.
- But I was a little psycho
when you think about it.
Like, "Hey, I'm here."
(laughter)
- She won't go away.
- You're living the dream though.
- I, well, be persistent
guys, but you know.
I think, thank God I have
kind eyes and not crazy eyes.
- I was gonna say, it'd
be hard to turn you away.
- [Ryan] Wow.
- You know?
- You willed it to be.
I willed it...
- You willed it.
- [Octavia] I willed it.
- Speaking of Will.
- That was awesome.
By the way, that's, that's
a talk show pro move.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- Talk show host pro move.
- [Host] Speaking of Will...
(clapping)
(audience cheering)
You willed it.
I'm willing this segue to Will.
Your most famous Christmas
movie, until now, was Elf.
Do people scream lines at
you all the time from it?
- Yeah, there's an
array of different lines
from the film that people will...
"I'm buddy the Elf."
"What's your favorite color?"
People will just say to me,
and I'm like, "You're buddy the Elf?"
(laughter)
"But I'm buddy the elf."
Anyway, they like to do that.
"Santa, I know him."
People will scream at me.
- [Host] Aw, Yeah.
- And, uh, "You sit on a throne of lies."
- [Ryan] Oh god yeah.
(laughter)
My daughters used that
on, on me every day.
- "Smell like beef and cheese."
- Yeah.
I'm assuming these were like
improvised or maybe not.
- Yeah, I think, I think
a fair, fair amount were.
- No, having known now, you did
a lot of writing on that
movie, I would guess.
- [Host] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Beef and Cheese was improvised.
(laughter)
- It was cheese and beef in the script.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- Right, right.